love this town the city of endless
opportunity ready to get your cherry
popped
come on city like any other just bigger
I just hit another city legends are born
here in nature weeks rolling your cos
Dex pulling the strings doubt that puts
cease and we lose them but we are they
just don't know it yet but if you got
the cojones and you know how to use them
you could do damn near anything unless
you catch it ball even then you go out
with a bang right you know you can make
heaps more a motivational speaker yo mr.
V a pleasure so what's the game Dex we
meant to come out in one piece
[Music]
how about we go over the plan there's
this prototype to biochip to be precise
jobs the plant
Desna belongs to a court heiress after
they robbed some heavy-hitters blackmail
me [ __ ]
how is have a war first full movie after
line to cut king baby
it goes without saying we do this on the
hush I deal in nobodies not a one sounds
simple enough
[Music]
is it gonna be dangerous don't you worry
we have more hack we're bulletproof what
the [ __ ] just happened in there it
stopped digging nice see [ __ ] me happy
now Jackie oh my god was so [ __ ]
[Music]
six what the [ __ ]
game risk opee and you who are you [ __ ]